Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui on va parler
de deux sujets sulfureux et controversés:
d'un côté l'énergie du vide quantique,
et de l'autre la fameuse somme 1+2+3+4+5 etc.
jusqu'à l'infini égale -1/12e.
Alors pour faire le lien entre ces 2 notions
on va examiner l'idée selon laquelle
certains phénomènes de physique quantique
seraient une "preuve"
du fait qu'1 + 2, + 3 etc. soit vraiment
égal à -1/12e.
Commençons par cette fameuse somme,
je ne vais pas revenir dessus bien longtemps
vous en avez certainement entendu parler.
En gros avec quelques manipulations simples,
mais complètement douteuses,
on peut démontrer que la somme
de tous les entiers,
de 1 jusqu'à l'infini,
vaudrait -1/12e.
Généralement quand on discute de ce résultat
surtout sur internet,
ça suscite 2 types de réactions grotesques.
Ceux qui pensent que c'est vrai,
c'est démontré
et que donc la somme de tous les entiers
vaut vraiment -1/12e,
ce qui paraît quand même un peu étonnant.
Et de l'autre on a des gens qui disent
que ça n'a aucun sens,
que c'est complètement débile
et totalement n'importe quoi
et qu'on pourrait aussi bien démontrer
que c'est égal à 42 ou racine de pi.
Et, ça aussi c'est une réaction exagérée.
Non, - 1/12e ça n'est pas
totalement n'importe quoi,
ce n'est pas une valeur prise au hasard,
car au-delà des démonstrations douteuses,
il y a des vrais concepts mathématiques
et un résultat
qu'on attribue notamment au mathématicien
indien Ramanujan.
Et ce que nous disent ses travaux,
ça n'est pas vraiment que la somme
de tous les entiers est "égale" à -1/12e,
en tout cas pas au sens classique.
Mais que sous certaines conditions,
on peut lui associer cette valeur.
Donc plutôt que de noter ça
avec un signe d'égalité,
on va le noter avec une flèche.
Et un argument qu'on entend parfois
pour soutenir le résultat de Ramanujan
c'est que la somme = -1/12e serait
"démontrée" par la physique quantique,
notamment par le calcul de
ce qu'on appelle "la force de Casimir"
qui est une force associée
à l'énergie du vide.
Alors le dire tel quel,
c'est évidemment faux, hein,
on ne démontre pas des théorèmes de maths
à partir de phénomènes physiques.
Ça ne prouve certainement pas
la véracité de l'affirmation,
mais ça nous montre qu'aussi intrigant
que soit ce résultat de – 1/12,
il peut peut-être servir à quelque chose.
C'est de ça dont on va parler aujourd'hui.
on va voir en quoi cette égalité bizarre
cache un truc suffisamment profond
pour que ça soit utile dans un certain
nombre de calculs en physique.
Pour ça on va parler de l'énergie du vide.
[Musique]
Bon, le vide intuitivement
c'est quand il n'y a rien hein,
pas de matière, pas d'atome,
pas d'électrons, pas de protons,
on pourrait dire que le vide
n'a pas d'énergie.
Mais même dans une zone
exempte de matière,
on peut quand même avoir des ondes
qui se propagent,
par exemple les ondes électromagnétiques,
la lumière, les ondes radio,
les rayons x, etc. et ces ondes
peuvent avoir une certaine énergie.
Bon OK, mais alors,
le vide vraiment vide?
Imaginez 1m³ d'espace, dans lequel
il n'y a pas de matière,
et où il n'y a même pas d'onde
qui se propage.
on a envie de dire qu'il ne contient
vraiment pas d'énergie.
Et pourtant, la physique quantique
semble nous dire le contraire.
Alors, pour comprendre ça, revenons
d'abord sur la notion d'onde,
avec un exemple familier, les vagues.
Imaginez un plan d'eau, vu de côté,
avec une certaine hauteur d'eau.
Une vague, on peut voir ça comme
une variation de la hauteur d'eau
en fonction de la position,
et qui évolue avec le temps.
Petite mise en garde:
les vraies vagues sont en fait
des ondes assez complexes dont la
forme n'est pas aussi simple que ça,
mais bon, gardons cette image.
Il y a 2 caractéristiques importantes:
la longueur d'onde qui est
l'espacement entre 2 pics,
et l'amplitude qui est
la hauteur de la vague.
Intuitivement l'amplitude
de l'onde va avoir un impact
sur l'énergie qu'elle contient,
plus l'amplitude est élevée
plus l'énergie de l'onde sera élevée.
dans le cas simple que j'ai dessiné
il n'y a qu'une longueur d'onde,
mais de façon générale on peut
superposer plusieurs ondes
avec des longueurs d'onde différentes.
Par exemple ici,
si j'ajoute celle-ci et celle-là,
et bien j'obtiens ça.
Et je pourrai encore
en ajouter d'autres si je veux.
Et quand j'ajoute des ondes
de longueurs d'ondes différentes
je peux m'amuser à varier l'amplitude
de chacune comme un cocktail
dont on ferait varier les proportions.
Quand on a une onde complexe
comme celle ci,
son énergie dépend de l'amplitude
de chacune des composantes.
Là évidemment on parle de vague,
mais pour le champ électromagnétique,
en gros ça marche pareil.
Les ondes électromagnétiques sont
une variation dans l'espace,
et dans le temps des champs électriques
et magnétiques.
Vous pouvez vous représenter ça
comme des vagues électromagnétiques.
Comme pour les vagues,
le champ électromagnétique peut avoir
différentes longueurs d'ondes,
et c'est ça qui détermine si on a
affaire à de la lumière visible,
des ondes radios, des rayons x, etc.
L'énergie correspondante sera liée
à l'amplitude, et à la longueur d'onde.
Pour essayer de calculer l'énergie
associée à un champ électromagnétique,
imaginons une situation concrète:
considérez 2 plaques métalliques
très grandes qui se font face
avec un certain écartement entre les 2,
supposons qu'elles soient faites
d'un métal qui conduise
parfaitement l'électricité.
Nos 2 deux plaques seront
comme des miroirs parfaits.
Cette configuration va imposer
une condition:
le champ électrique existant entre les 2
devra forcément être nul
au niveau des plaques.
On se retrouve alors dans une situation
qui n'est pas très différente
de celle d'une corde de guitare.
Avec cette condition voyons
les longueurs d'onde qui peuvent exister:
il y à celle ci, celle là, celle
là, et ainsi de suite.
Si on note "x" l'écart entre les plaques
les longueurs d'onde possibles sont:
"x", "x/2", "x/3" et de façon générale "x/n"
où "n" c'est n'importe quel entier.
Pour estimer l'énergie contenue
dans ces ondes électromagnétiques,
on va considérer chaque longueur
d'onde indépendamment.
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que l'énergie
d'une onde était liée à son amplitude,
on peut voir ça comme l'amplitude du champ
électrique ou magnétique qui oscille.
Mais on peut aussi voir ça
d'une autre manière,
grâce à la dualité: onde/corpuscule
qui nous vient de la mécanique quantique.
L'énergie d'une onde qui existe
entre les 2 plaques va être liée
au nombre de photons qui s'y trouvent.
pour compter précisément l'énergie
associée à ces photons
on va devoir faire appel
à la mécanique quantique.
On sait en mécanique quantique
que l'énergie d'un photon
est égale à "h" fois "c" divisé par lambda",
ou lambda c'est sa longueur d'onde,
"h" la fameuse constante de Planck,
et "c", la vitesse de la lumière.
Bon, "h" et "c" sont des constantes,
donc l'énergie d'un photon ne dépend
que de sa longueur d'onde.
Plus celle-ci est courte
plus l'énergie sera élevée,
donc si vous avez un photon
qui se balade entre les plaques,
l'énergie sera "hc/lambda".
Si vous avez 4 photons
ce sera 4 fois hc/lambda,
et puis si vous en avez 42
ce sera 42 fois hc/lambda, etc. facile!
Et s'il y a zéro photons,
l'énergie ce sera zéro non?
Eh ben pas tout à fait!
Vous connaissez le principe
d'incertitude d'Heisenberg?
Celui qui dit qu'on ne peut pas
fixer précisément à la fois
la vitesse et la position
d'une particule?
Eh bien ça a des conséquences
sur les énergies de ces particules.
Imaginez un tout petit objet
attaché à un ressort,
et qui peut donc osciller
du fait de ce ressort.
Pour que l'ensemble ait une énergie nulle
il faudrait à la fois
que l'objet soit parfaitement immobile,
à une vitesse nulle,
mais aussi qu'il soit parfaitement
à la position d'équilibre,
où le ressort est au repos.
Eh bien, en mécanique quantique
ça n'est pas possible,
on ne peut pas fixer à la fois
vitesse et position parfaitement.
Et donc un objet attaché à un ressort
aura toujours comme une sorte
de mini oscillation, et donc
une toute petite énergie résiduelle.
On appelle ça "l'énergie de point zéro".
Eh bien le champ électromagnétique,
c'est un peu pareil,
pour des raisons similaires,
son énergie ne peut jamais être
complètement nulle, il y a toujours
un petit résidu,
une "énergie de point zéro".
On peut calculer la valeur
de cette énergie,
et c'est la moitié de l'énergie
d'un photon, soit 1/2 de hc/lambda.
C'est comme si à cause
des effets quantiques,
il y avait toujours comme un demi-photon
fantôme qui se baladait entre les plaques.
Sauf que ça c'est pour
une longueur d'onde lambda,
on a dit qu'entre nos 2 plaques
il y avait tout un tas
de longueurs d'onde possibles.
Et pour chacune de ces longueurs d'ondes,
il faut calculer l'énergie de point zéro.
Alors allons-y, faisons le calcul:
on a noté "x", l'espacement des plaques,
pour la 1ère première longueur d'onde
l'énergie de point zéro, c'est 1/2 de hc/x,
pour la 2ème longueur d'onde
qui est 2 fois plus courte,
l'énergie c'est 1/2 de hc/x/2,
en fait ça fait la même énergie
qu'au dessus, multipliée par 2.
la 3ème longueur d'onde, ben
toujours la même énergie, mais
multipliée par 3 cette fois etc.
Si on additionne tout ça pour toutes
les longueurs d'ondes qui peuvent exister
entre les 2 plaques, on obtient:
1/2 de hc/x, multiplié par (1+2+3+4+5, etc.)
jusqu'à l'infini .
Aïe! il y a un nombre infini
de longueurs d'ondes possibles,
et quand on additionne l'énergie
de point zéro pour chacune
ben on trouve l'infini.
Il y a une énergie infinie
contenue entre les plaques!
Qu'est ce qu'on va faire?
En fait c'est peut-être pas si grave
on peut essayer de contourner le problème,
vous savez peut-être que de façon générale
générale quand on parle d'énergie,
on peut toujours changer
le point de référence.
On le fait par exemple avec l'énergie
potentielle de pesanteur
suivant l'altitude qu'on considère
comme étant le zéro.
Ce qui permet de changer le point
de référence, c'est qu'en physique
ce qui compte souvent, ça n'est pas
l'énergie en tant que telle,
mais ses variations, de combien
l'énergie va-t-elle changer
si je passe d'un point à un autre?
C'est ça qui détermine
notamment les forces.
Là qu'est-ce qui se passe
pour l'énergie si je modifie
un tout petit peu la valeur de "x"?
Ben ça fait changer l'énergie
d'une quantité infinie,
ça veut dire qu'il y a une force
infinie entre les plaques.
Alors pour ceux qui aiment les détails
on prend la dérivée de l'énergie
c'est ça qui donne la force s’exerçant.
et là l'énergie est infinie,
mais sa dérivée aussi.
Donc on est en train de dire qu'il y a
une force infinie qui s'exerce
entre les 2 plaques, une force infinie
qui les fait se repousser.
Aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe!
C'est bizarre parce que quand
j'approche 2 plaques métalliques
l'une de l'autre dans la vraie vie
je n'ai pas une force infinie
qui les fait se repousser.
Bon, qu'est ce qu'on va faire?
Il y aurait bien une solution,
on a vu que quand on calculait l'énergie
on faisait apparaître l'expression
1+2+3+4+5… jusqu'à l'infini,
et bien on n'a qu'à la remplacer par -1/12e
puisqu'on a vu avec Ramanujan,
qu'on peut associer la valeur -1/12e
à la somme de tous les entiers.
Bon, si on fait ça, l'énergie vaut alors
–1/24e de "hc" divisé par "x",
c'est une énergie finie.
La force associée c'est -1/24e de "hc"
sur x², et on a une force finie
qui s'exerce entre les 2 plaques.
C'est une force attractive cette fois,
qui tend à les faire se rapprocher,
c'est plutôt cool non?
Non mais je plaisante,
c'est complètement absurde
ce qu'on vient de faire là, on ne va pas
remplacer la somme des entiers par -1/12e!
Une valeur négative en plus!
Et du coup la force répulsive infinie
devient une force attractive finie,
non mais n'importe quoi!
Non, On va essayer de trouver autre chose
en réfléchissant à la physique de la chose.
[Générique]
Quand je fais mon calcul des longueurs
d'ondes entre les plaques
il y a un truc qui paraît
un peu bizarre physiquement.
Mes plaques sont espacées de "x"
et je considère les longueurs d'ondes
de "x", "x/2", "x/3", "x/n",
pour n aussi grand qu'on veut.
Donc même si "x" c'est disons 1 cm
avec "n" qui vaut 10 puissance 40,
ça veut dire que je pars du principe
qu'il y à des longueurs d'ondes
du champ électromagnétique qui valent
10 puissance -40 cm,
et pareil avec 10^-100 ou 10^-1000:
des longueurs d'onde aussi petites qu'on veut.
C'est assez bizarre de supposer ça
car on peut facilement s'imaginer
qu'il y à une échelle de distance en-dessous
de laquelle la physique va changer,
on ne peut plus considérer que
que l’électromagnétisme fonctionne
de la même façon, par exemple
quand on essaye d'unifier
mécanique quantique et relativité générale,
on considère souvent qu'il doit y avoir
des effets de gravité quantique qui modifient
la structure de l'espace-temps
à très petite échelle, en général autour
de la longueur de Planck: 10^-33 cm.
Alors on ne sait pas exactement
ce que sont ces effets,
Est-ce que l'espace temps devient une mousse
quantique ou un truc de ce genre?
On n'en sait rien et différentes théories
comme la théorie des cordes,
ou la gravité quantique à boucles, vont
peut-être prédire des choses différentes.
Mais que ce soit une mouche quantique
ou autre chose, il n'est pas absurde
de supposer qu'on a pas le droit de parler
de longueur d'onde de l'électromagnétisme
qui soit infiniment petite,
sans prendre en compte que quelque chose
de différent va se produire en-dessous
d'une certaine échelle.
Une façon assez générique de faire,
c'est de supposer qu'il existe
une certaine longueur d'onde, on va
l'appeler lambda c, "c" comme coupure,
au-delà de laquelle les choses changent.
Et on doit arrêter d'ajouter l'énergie
du champ électromagnétique associé
comme si de rien n'était.
Une façon radicale ce serait de dire
qu'au delà de lambda c,
on arrête de compter les énergies
de point zéro.
C'est un peu brutal, souvent les choses
ne s'arrêtent pas forcément
d'un coup sec quand on passe un seuil.
On peut supposer un truc plus progressif,
où par exemple on va supprimer peu à peu
les énergies associées en utilisant
une exponentielle décroissante.
Je vous épargne les détails des calculs,
je vous les mets quand même pour les furieux,
mais si on fait ça, et bien on trouve
un résultat fini, pour l'énergie, super!
Le seul souci c'est que ça dépend
évidemment de la longueur d'onde
de coupure lambda c, qu'on ne connaît pas,
on voit que si lambda c est très petit
comme on peut le supposer,
ça va quand même faire une énergie
monstrueusement élevée.
Donc on n'est pas tellement avancé.
Mais il y a un truc qu'on oublie:
il peut y avoir des ondes électromagnétiques
entre les plaques, et donc
de l'énergie associée,
Mais des ondes, il peut aussi y en avoir
à l'extérieur des plaques,
peut-être qu'il faut le prendre en compte
parce que si l'espacement "x" change,
ça va avoir un impact sur les ondes
existant à la fois,
à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur.
Pour traiter ça d'une façon qui ait
un sens expérimentalement,
voici ce qu'on va faire:
on va supposer qu'une des plaques est fixe
et que l'autre peut bouger
si jamais il y a une force.
et très loin ici on va mettre
une autre plaque, fixe également.
Prenez une distance "L",
très grande entre les 2,
la taille de la pièce ou la taille
de l'univers si ça vous amuse.
Maintenant on va compter à la fois
l'énergie entre les 2 plaques,
mais aussi l'énergie dans le grand
compartiment ici.
on va les ajouter en utilisant
notre formule de tout-à-l'heure
et comme ce qui nous intéresse
ça n'est pas tant l'énergie que la force,
on va regarder ce qu'il se passe
quand on fait varier "x",
quand on prend la dérivée de tout ça.
Eh bien on voit que la longueur
d'onde de coupure disparaît,
et si on suppose que "L"
est très très grand,
on se retrouve avec une expression
pour la force qui est parfaitement
raisonnable, finie, qui dépend ni de "L",
ni de la longueur d'onde de coupure,
et c'est une force attractive qui pousse
les plaques à se rapprocher.
Et si on regarde bien cette expression,
ah ben mince!
C'est exactement ce qu'on avait
quand on avait simplement remplacé
1+2+3+4… par -1/12e, c'est fou ça!
Est-ce que c'est juste un hasard?
Alors non, ça n'est pas
un coup de chance miraculeux.
Le fait que -1/12e apparaisse ici,
ça cache en fait un truc assez profond.
Mais je dois d'abord préciser
quelques petits trucs.
Tout d'abord le calcul qu'on a fait-là,
en supposant une longueur d'onde de coupure,
une décroissance exponentielle,
c'est un résultat robuste hein.
On aurait pu prendre autre chose
qu'une décroissance exponentielle,
on aurait trouvé pareil.
Le fait que le résultat ne dépende,
ni de la longueur d'onde de coupure,
ni de la façon dont celle-ci
va se manifester,
ça veut dire qu'on arrive
à calculer des choses
sur ce qui se passe à nos échelles,
malgré notre ignorance de la physique exacte,
aux plus petites échelles.
Ici le résultat ne dépend pas vraiment
des détails des phénomènes physiques
qui se produiraient éventuellement
à l'échelle de Planck par exemple.
C'est pratique, ça veut dire qu'on peut
faire de l'électromagnétisme
sans avoir préalablement résolu le problème
de la gravité quantique.
Ensuite, un point extrêmement important,
c'est que cette force attractive
elle existe vraiment, on sait la mesurer.
C'est une force qu'on appelle
la force de Casimir,
du nom de son découvreur.
Alors Casimir c'est pas le monstre gentil,
c'est un physicien théoricien néerlandais.
Cette force attractive avait donc
été théorisée par Casimir en 1948,
mais elle est très compliquée à mesurer,
il faut une précision incroyable.
Et ça n'a été fait de façon convaincante
pour la 1ère fois qu'en 1997,
avec une configuration un peu différente
de celle qu'on a discutée.
Alors maintenant que peut-on conclure
de cette histoire de remplacer
la somme de tous les entiers par -1/12e?
On voit que si on le fait dès le départ,
eh bien c'est une manière rapide
d'obtenir le bon résultat,
une sorte de raccourci.
Alors ça a l'air d'être une opération
illicite, et stricto sensu,
évidemment on n'a pas le droit,
mais c'est une manière implicite
de prendre en compte cette histoire de
différence d'énergie, entre les plaques,
et avec le monde extérieur.
Mais si on ne prend pas le raccourci,
qu'on fait le calcul rigoureux
comme je l'ai expliqué, eh bien on voit
explicitement le -1/12e apparaître.
Cette valeur n'est pas là par hasard.
Pour celles et ceux qui veulent creuser,
il y a de vrais résultats mathématiques
qui justifient le sens de cette constante,
comme une sorte de différence entre
un infini qui serait une somme discrète
entre les plaques, et un infini
continu en dehors.
En conclusion, remplacer la somme
des entiers par -1/12e,
on peut le faire comme un raccourci
dans un calcul de physique,
mais seulement quand on comprend
exactement ce qu'on fait,
et qu'on sait bien
ce que ça implique en coulisse.
Un autre endroit où se raccourci apparait,
c'est en théorie des cordes.
Quand j'ai appris la théorie des cordes,
j'étais en thèse à l'époque,
j'utilisai entre-autre un livre
qui est un classique, le livre de Polchinski.
Et dans les 1ers chapitres, on se retrouve
dans une situation
où on fait la somme de tous les entiers,
à cause de la quantification des modes
de vibration de la corde.
Et là, l'auteur balance tranquille ça:
il remplace la somme des entiers par -1/12e
et continue comme si de rien n'était.
Alors ça m'avait super choqué à l'époque,
parce qu'en plus
il s'agit d'un calcul absolument essentiel
en théorie des cordes.
En fait c'est le calcul qui permet
de déterminer en quelles dimensions
la théorie des cordes peut fonctionner.
Vous savez peut-être que suivant la version,
il faut 10 ou 26 dimensions,
sinon la théorie ne peut pas marcher,
il y a des anomalies qui apparaissent.
Et donc on cherche en quelles dimensions
il faut se mettre
pour faire disparaître les anomalies.
Donc pourquoi 26 et pas autre chose?
Eh bien quand on regarde le détail,
ça vient vraiment du -1/12e.
Pour annuler le terme anormal
on voit qu'il faut "d=26",
et si on retrace l'origine de ce 26
eh bien ça vient vraiment de -1/12e.
Je vous disais que j'avais été choqué
à l'époque de voir qu'un résultat
aussi essentiel de la théorie des cordes:
le nombre de dimensions nécessaires,
venait d'un truc aussi absurde que
de remplacer la somme des entiers par -1/12e!
Et évidemment derrière cette pirouette il y a,
comme dans le cas de la force de Casimir,
un raisonnement physique qui permet
de le faire proprement.
Remplacer par -1/12e, c'est un raccourci
mathématique
qui permet d'accélérer le calcul
quand on sait ce qu'on fait.
Bien j'espère que cette petite clarification
vous aura permis d'apprécier et de comprendre
les utilisations en physique de la fameuse
somme des entiers qui vaut -1/12e.
On ne peut évidemment pas dire
que la force de Casimir
soit une démonstration de ce résultat,
mais ça montre l'utilité en physique,
des approches mathématiques
qu'il y a derrière.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
si vous voulez creuser,
je vous encourage vivement à aller lire
les différents articles de blog
que j'ai écrit sur le sujet, je mets
les liens en description,
comme toujours partagez la vidéo,
mettez des pouces et des cloches,
et puis nous, on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt.
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'Oreille -